it made look and sound like any other
day on the streets of Paris on the eve
of the euro final you need only to
interrupt a morning coffee to get a hit
of snowballing enthusiasts for the
courts one of you good good la fonts
forward now the team has come so far and
also beat in Germany now we are all
enthusiastic yes whenever my up TT
everyone is behind the team and that's
great we are already excited and really
looking forward to the final the well so
much the French know how to win at home
nineteen eighty four European champions
and 1998 world champions thanks to
another than zinedine zidane now nearly
two decades after those feats the new
generation has the opportunity to win
the european title the french they
believe it's their time again Virginia
I'm sure we will win portugal only has
one good player cristiano ronaldo that's
not enough we're in the final come on
france we will get past Portugal's
there's wildlife concert I think three
nil Antoine Griezmann to score the goals
90,000 fans are expected at the fan zone
in Paris regimes in the mood for another
fantastic party and one with a truly
magnificent centerpiece
you